then I'm about to walk down and they  like start playing the song and I'm just  like and it just it starts coming and  then her song and it just comes more and  I'm just looking down the whole time  because I'm I can't I can't even look at  anyone in the crowd it's [ __ ] me up  so bad and then she walks out and I'm  like go back inside  this is way too vulnerable you're too  beautiful yeah literally I'm like I  can't handle it I'm gonna try like way  more than I have planned dude your dress  is banging that's what I said yo you  look hot as [ __ ] by the way I want to  [ __ ] lay you down right now yeah yeah  cannot wait to consummate this marriage  also your tits look insane I can't stay  up here much longer get me out of here  can I read my I was fully torqued or  that'd be weird  no instead I just like wept like a child